ein held ohne geld japans regeln und
normen eroberte egal
er hat seinen eigenen kompass auch ein
revoluzzer yutaka schulverweigerer
lieber frei als angepasst ich lerne zu
hause wären die schule möchte bitte als
frau im männer job yukiko tomita sagt
nein zu japans rollenbild da bin ich
wohl ein seltener fall
und fängt noch mal von vorne an
[Musik]
stark schreien start frei für die 100
kilometer von newco hashi nach bedburg
nach einer minute runter an den fluss da
liegt noch eine rot ist seine farbe
roboter st der hat heute geburtstag wird
80 trotzdem läuft damit nur etwas später
roboter macht immer sein und titan jacke
ich will nicht auffallen mich aber auch
nicht verstecken ich verstoße nicht
gegen das gesetz
aber ich mache einfach wie es mir passt
wohin der eigenbrötler auch geht sein
guter ruf ist schon da er hört nicht
gern aber er ist ein held japans
bekanntester ehrenamtlicher helfer
popularität die schon mal im wege steht
bitte recht freundlich
er hat doch kinder gerettet haben im
vorbeifahren erkannt wollte ihm
unbedingt mal die hand schütteln da habe
ich kurz angehalten
ich bin cool wie superman für das glück
der kinder steht dafür marschiert er
aber nach seinen regeln ein
individualist seltene spezies in japan
roberta sagt die gesellschaft sei kalt
sie brauche wärme mitgefühl
sein credo tuwas ohne gegenleistung der
100 kilometer lauf aber kennt kein
mitgefühl oder aufgeben das wäre traurig
wenn ich es versuche aber nicht schaffe
ist das in ordnung entscheidend ist die
herausforderung wie ein samurai es wagen
und ertragen
[Musik]
okinawa hier ist japan anders dazu sagt
man doch gerne
ja
auch der us-armee gefällt es hier es
dröhnen die rotoren als im kino an im
haus hinter der giraffe ein grundschüler
aus der reihe tanzt 11 uhr morgens und
yutaka nakamura sollte eigentlich in der
schule sein
doch der weigert sich mit billigung der
eltern stattdessen ausflugsprogramm mit
den jüngeren schwester wir haben ein
haus gemietet mit pool da kann ich viel
spaß haben mit allen das ist das größte
und was wenn du in die schule gehen
würdest
da wäre ich vielleicht nur zum
mittagessen hin und dann wieder nach
hause
da steht genie und dem gefällt japans
erstarrter schulbetrieb nicht leben
heißt doch abenteuer
es ist ja nicht so dass mein sohn die
ganze zeit zu hause hockt er begegnet
vielen leuten und wertvorstellungen
so können kinder auf was lernen das ist
doch eine gute sache
in der zweiten klasse bekam yutaka
schläge vom lehrer der leugnete erst gab
es dann zu der pädagoge war überfordert
die familie zog von busacca nach okinawa
hier weht ein liberaler wind
sohn und vater ein team sie singen von
einem blatt
[Musik]
ich denke die japanische schulbildung
ist nicht mehr zeitgemäß wenn man fragt
was für die kinder von heute in der
gesellschaft von morgen nötig ist dann
ist das doch individualität eine
persönliche note zwischenstopp auf der
autobahn die einkäufe kriegt der
selbstläufer auch ohne eltern hin
etwa 80 euro taschengeld bekommt er im
monat manchmal mehr
fürs abendessen bilder thunfisch und
krabbenfleisch imitat
[Musik]
und für einen der mit dem handy zur welt
gekommen ist ist auch die
selbstbedienungs kassel kein hindernis
[Musik]
ich mache das alles allein weil ich das
selber ordentlich berechnen möchte und
er hatte das beigebracht ich mir selbst
[Musik]
der jugendrevolution er sieht aus wie
ein kinderdarsteller doch er sagt dem
schul drill den kampf an
auf youtube im pool klassentreffen der
schulverweigerer samt eltern netzwerk
das traurige kinder bewahren möchte vor
der schulpflicht regelverstoß im
harmoniesüchtigen japan größter
unruhestifter yutaka seinen aktionen
möchte unser sohn einen anderen kindern
mitteilen dass schulverweigerung kein
unglück ist ich glaube das macht er zum
einen für die kinder zum anderen aber
auch für sich selbst
das bildungssystem ein druckkessel der
zwang zur konformität führt zu frust und
der zum mobbingopfer banner utah das
beste freundin
[Musik]
als sie schikaniert wurde und nicht mehr
zur schule gehen konnte
da hat utah mich unterstützt ich wollte
sterben aber er hat gesagt du bist echt
in ordnung das hat mir geholfen unter
minderjährigen steigt die selbstmordrate
also duldet japan schulverweigerung
bevor es noch schlimmer kommt die kinder
diskutieren über ein system dass talente
klein hält und rituale hochschüler noch
die farbe der haare diktiert und die der
unterwäsche und das gerade erst die sitz
strafe im knie verboten hat das alles
auf youtube lernen mit freude das muss
doch gehen
warum muss es eine japanische schule
sein
man kann auch außerhalb japans lernen
das ist doch nichts für ein bestimmtes
alter mann lernt sein leben lang und was
man ja will das lernt man was nicht dass
nicht sie zündeln an der ordnung und ja
das macht dann mal spaß
im haus hinter der giraffe lässt yutaka
tags darauf die partie revue passieren
für seine mehr als 100.000 youtube
abonnenten darunter viele
schulverweigerer dir zitat retten möchte
und später was ich mal werden will
ich bin ja schon was ich sein will aber
es gibt noch viele dinge die ich machen
möchte
[Musik]
ob man die schule verweigert oder zopf
trägt als haar spende für krebskranke
abweichler in japan kriegen was zu hören
stirbt einfach verschwinden ab aus japan
und sowas gibt's am häufigsten aber
yutaka hört nicht mehr hin
der will erstmal kinder retten sein
mantra geht niemals aus
[Musik]
tokio so weit das auge reicht
viele wollen rein aber eine will raus
[Musik]
yukiko tomita packt ein mit mitte
dreißig und neuer job neues heim 600
kilometer entfernt als schiffbau
ingenieure sind selten und frauen die
von tokio auf land wollen noch viel mehr
ich bin also ein sehr seltener fall aber
es wäre gut wenn andere menschen
erkennen würden dass es auch leute die
mich gibt toyota kato mieter sie
verneinen klischees und gruppenzwang der
typus heißt in japan eisbrecher doch das
alles ist dicker als am pol da war tony
kanal mit der uni als ich meinem vater
damals gesagt habe was ich studieren
will war er zuerst strikt dagegen
er meinte nur sowas brauchen mädchen
nicht ich war auf einer reinen
mädchenschule vor mir war von da noch
nie eine auf meine uni gegangen hat mir
eine spätere absolventen erzählt das
habe ich bis heute nicht vergessen
die liebe zu mehr geben ihr die eltern
mit der vater hatte leider einen
schlaganfall ist jetzt im pflegeheim
ihren alten job hatte mieter gekündigt
und war vorübergehend wieder zuhause
eingezogen
die mutter sah man kann ja viel übers
handy machen und zum beispiel fotos
schicken so weiß ich dass es ihr gut
geht das ist ja die größte sorge einer
mutter
[Musik]
raus aus tokio aber nicht ohne
kühlschrank tomita hat noch nie selber
eingekauft durch das haushaltsgeräte
mekka akihabara kriegt jeden
ausstaffiert lieferung frei haus japan
weit ich weiß nicht wie das ist auf dem
land eventuell habe ich der falsche
vorstellungen hier ist die auswahl auf
jeden fall groß und vielleicht ist das
auch billiger
tokios freizeitwelt verlockend die
arbeitswelt hart besonders für frauen
hierarchisch verkrustet oft
frauenfeindlich visite beim alten
arbeitgeber auch wenn man logisch
argumentiert heißt es hört einfach auf
das was ich sage und es ändert sich
nichts habe ich mehrfach erlebt und beim
nächsten firmen umtrunk wurde mir dann
gesagt du hältst den mund in sichtweite
eine nachbildung der freiheitsstatue
yuki kozo mieter war so frei zu kündigen
und auch vom anderen geschlecht hat sie
sich vorübergehend frei gemacht es passt
gerade nicht ich dachte früher schon
dass ich mal heiraten möchte und bis vor
einigen jahren hatte ich auch einen
freund
aber wenn einem die beziehung das nimmt
was man eigentlich möchte im leben dann
bin ich lieber allein
umzüge in japan eine kunst nichts kommt
weg nichts geht kaputt
tomita packt jetzt ein was ihr lieb und
teuer ist persönliches werkzeug
ingenieur hammer spachtel rolle gabel
schlüssel handverlesen der letzte karton
und am ziel der erste so hat sie sich
das gedacht so einen umzug mache ich zum
ersten mal
jetzt spüre ich dass ich so schnell wohl
nicht mehr zurückkommen
nach vorne schauen selbstbewusst
nächster halt immer buddy westjapan
guten morgen um sechs die 100 kilometer
gestern waren zuviel für butter nach 60
hatte ihn seine tochter eingesammelt
aber weiter geht's morgen routine
gesundheit ist das höchste gut solange
man gesund ist muss man von nichts angst
haben komme was wolle
außer es kommt eine frau mutter lebt in
südjapan nabu bekannt für seine heißen
quellen roboter ist selber eine deshalb
hat ihn seine frau auch verlassen das
tempo war zu hoch mit mitte 60 schloss
er sein fischgeschäft erlebe jetzt als
freiwilliger helfer erfuhr die familie
nun reist der taifun und erdbeben
hinterher nie leise aber sehr weise ich
fühle mich in den anderen hinein
mal angenommen hier passiert ein tsunami
oder erdrutsch oder mein haus versinkt
in einer erdspalte dann wäre ich froh
wenn mir auch jemand hilft und gut zu
spricht knapp 500 euro rente im monat
mehr hat er nicht japan sklavische
ordnung roboter hat seine eigene
das sehe nur unordentlich aus sagt er
aber alles sei an seinem platz
und außerdem müsse er sicher
zurechtfinden system obert erster
recyceln taugt doch gut geölt noch als
werkzeug der als freiwilliger helfer
werkzeug einpackt dass sich nur noch mit
beiden händen öffnen lässt der ist
durchgefallen
regel 2 in obersfeld einfach essen reis
bildchen mit salzig eingelegter pflaume
täglich im supermarkt kostet so 1 100
yen aber selbst gemacht nur etwa 30 und
erkenntnis nummer drei anerkennung ist
schön aber nur wenn sie auch von den
richtigen kopf wenn ich danke es
nachrichten von grundschulkindern lese
dann kommen mir immer die trennung so
gerührt bin ich die freundlich sich mal
mehr als die worte eines
premierministers egal von welchem er
selbst lebt wie im notstandsgebiet der
freut sich über die kleinen dinge
fanpost
sehr geehrter herr oberteil ich
bewundere sie ich hoffe diese dinge
nutzen ihnen bitte achten sie auf ihre
gesundheit absender kennt er nicht
wir helfen mit instant reis fertigsuppen
dann hockt er sich vor die flimmerkiste
geschenk seiner tochter und beobachtet
taifun nummer 19 richtet der schaden an
könnte das seine hilfe erfordern roboter
ist bereit und die reisbällchen sind es
auch
die nova rock ihn aber dass chemie
bürstet heute mal seinen aufmüpfigen
alltag gegen den strich yutaka der
schulverweigerer wird zur schule
es ist acht uhr 15 eigentlich müsste
schon seit einer viertelstunde da sein
ach es reicht wenn ich um halb neun da
bin
zeit ist relativ
[Musik]
die schule ist gleich um die ecke den
ganzen morgen schon zieht die karawane
der kleinsten und yutaka vorbei und
jetzt kinder überraschung der
schulschwänzer stürmt in die lehranstalt
und freust du dich englisch also doch
aber nur keine lust hat mutter
webdesignerin vater psychologischer
berater reicht zum leben im home-office
papa nokia war früher selbst nicht ohne
vorzeitig von der schule diebstahl
drogen gelegenheitsjobs mittlerweile ist
der autor eines psychologie ratgebers
und froh dass er die kurve gekriegt hat
und dass er der ehemals halbstarke in
der mitte da doch noch seinen abschluss
nachholen konnte viele glauben wir in
der grund und mittelschule nicht
ordentlich lernt bekommt später probleme
ich denke wer als erwachsener unbedingt
noch etwas lernen möchte der kann darin
herausragend werden was andere über
yutaka denken unwichtig ihr kinder guru
öffnet türen kommt rum lernt so fürs
leben
[Musik]
anfangs wollte ich dass er wieder zur
schule geht aber dann fragte ich mich
sage ich das zu judas wohl und merkte
ich sagte das nur für mich und die leute
draußen
er soll sich frei entwickeln nach seinen
interessen aber ohne das gesetz zu
brechen
englisch ist aus japanisch mark yutaka
nicht schule für beendet erklärt
freigang
diese kann die japanische schriftzeichen
grauenhaft warum sollte er sich damit
belasten reden und rechnen kann er mehr
brauchte nicht im kiosk freunde wären
gut aber die haben ja schule also
knabbert er am tintenfisch und hofft
dass was passiert
später homeschooling die kann sie sind
im weg also verließ die elektronische
assistent in die nachricht rocky navas
zahl der grund schulverweigerer in einem
jahr um 30 prozent gestiegen
kein wunder sagt yutaka immer mehr
schikane auch von den lehrern im
internet steht ganz viel dazu braucht
yutaka noch schule alten stils wie und
was lernen wenn es morgen schon überholt
ist macht er jetzt alles falsch oder
alles richtig wo bleiben soziale
kontakte gespräche freunde
die könnten jetzt mal langsam aus der
schule kommen
langeweile ist universell
sein kumpel leo hat dann später doch
noch zeit für ihn
der junge hatte erst noch hausaufgaben
zu erledigen
bei allen zweifeln an seiner schulischen
nicht aktivitäten sozial isolierte
scooter kann nicht wir mögen ihn sagt
leo er erzählt immer so viel
interessantes yutaka staunt findet eine
raupe und wir die gewissheit er ist eben
doch nur ein kleiner junge im
abenteuerland
tokio haneda yuki kozo mieters maschine
flugzeit in ihre neue zukunft eine
stunde und 35 minuten
daran
heute morgen habe ich mich irgendwie
einsam gefühlt melancholisch aber wenn
ich hier aus dem fenster schaue dann
denke ich jetzt ist es soweit
gereon
schiffe bauen in westjapan bedeutet nur
150.000 mitbewohner in imbaba die stadt
38 millionen in tokio vollbremsung
ohne ski der ort mit der werft in der
für tomica ab jetzt die funken fliegen
für ihre verhältnisse ein stillleben die
beste unterhaltung in bahnhofsnähe
verspricht noch der getränkeautomat auf
dem land gibt es noch viele solcher orte
im gegensatz zur großstadt ist hier kein
lernen unglaublich angenehm und ihr
neues domizil erreicht sie tatsächlich
zu fuß
die stadt die werft untrennbar verbunden
seit 1961 das neue zuhause tomita
bekommt eine geräumige firmen wohnung
für lächerliche 120 euro im monat
die gleich das gehaltsgefälle gegenüber
tokio mehr als aus fotos für mama die
botschaft gut angekommen alles in
ordnung so eine wohnung hier würde man
in tokio gar nicht finden für eine
einzelne person undenkbar der
umzugswagen timing ist alles roboter
gleich checklisten gesteuert automieter
weiß sofort wo es ist ihr wertvollstes
stück der hammer ist sowas wie mein
talisman seit beginn meiner arbeit und
damit ich ihn gleich benutzen kann habe
ich ihn oben in den ersten karton gelegt
spediteur watanabe hat schon viel
gesehen und erlebt aber eine frau hier
im schiffbau
[Musik]
na das ist ja wirklich eine tolle
geschichte wäre schön ist kaum noch mehr
junge frau nach immer badi dann wäre es
hier sicher lebhafter
noch einmal schlafen dann geht es
endlich los
in córdoba docyard kilometer tank
nochmal frische luft der strand ist
gleich nebenan
sie hat sich viel vorgenommen wieder
englisch lernen alte freunde einladen
neue gewinnen
auch abseits der arbeit ich gehe ja ganz
gerne mal was trinken aber wenn ich hier
leute finde mit denen ich mich gut
verstehe
dann könnten wir uns auch bei denen
treffen oder bei mir so ein verhältnis
würde ich gern aufbauen
mit schwung in den tag
obert führt seine letzte große liebe aus
die kleine honda
der taifun ist abgedreht entwarnung so
macht das energiebündel klar schiff am
wasser und meckert über das ganze
plastik doch der lebenskünstler denkt
praktisch die röhrchen von den
austernbänken die denken sich warum denn
auf den müll
also nehme ich sie mit nach hause und
mache signal pfeifen daraus für notfälle
da freuen sie sich bestimmt und sagen
danke ortstermin in petto nachbarschaft
chef udo lädt ein oberteil möge bitte
das gefahrenbewusstsein der lokalen
bevölkerung schärfen
man kennt sich als er noch den fisch
geladen hatte war in der ganzen
nachbarschaft zu hören er ist auch jetzt
noch laut er sagte menschen wetteifern
mit ihren stimmen deshalb solle man
immer aus voller kehle rufen
das habe ich gelernt von ihm herbert das
ist doch sonntag und sie sitzen trotzdem
hier
das hängt von der anfrage ab nur zum
quatschen komme ich nicht her ein
pflegeheim für demenzkranke die
evakuierungsübung feuerlöschen sich
bemerkbar machen
aber da packt die pfeifen aus die selbst
gebastelten aus treibgut erstes opfer
die heimleiterin
[Musik]
wieso kann ich das nicht aber opa darf
nicht mithelfen die versicherung die
statuten
also gibt er das maskottchen nicht
schlimm ist auch nicht seine welt so ein
altersheim
[Musik]
also ich möchte da nicht rein
selbst wenn ich irgendwann in dem
zustand bin ich würde doch lieber zu
hause gepflegt
ganz ehrlich feuerwehr und sober tag
schon das nachbarhaus gelöscht
kinderspiel
apropos roboter muss weiter auf einen
kinderspielplatz gefahrenabwehr im
sandkasten
wir werden es erlebt
lara okinawa teenager beim uniformierten
schaulaufen schulschluss
nur einer war mal wieder gar nicht in
der schule denn reduziert lieber selbst
roger carr der schulverweigerer kamera
läuft freundin maya ist auch der parole
nicht aufgeben leben heißt abenteuer zur
reichweiten stärkung bestreitet der
youtube-star auch noch seine eigene
internet radio show titel das tor zur
freiheit und bitte in der sendung heute
geht es um mobbing an der schule und was
das für die opfer bedeutet mama erzählt
von sich und ihrem dunkelsten kapitel
das sich schon während der ersten klasse
nicht mehr zur schule gehen und nachts
nicht mehr schlafen konnte
darüber kann sie jetzt sogar lachen was
sie denn damals gemacht habe möchte
yutaka dann wissen ich habe mir deine
videos angesehen die haben wir geholfen
und meine mama hat dann über die
facebook gruppe deinen papa
angeschrieben und dann besteht sie dass
sie immer einsam war und noch nie eine
geburtstagsparty gemacht habe aber jetzt
und yutaka sei herzlich eingeladen
der findet das cool und kommt gerne
vorbei fazit bloß nicht unterkriegen
lassen
ein schöner erfolg der gehört ins
familienalbum
ihren helfer roboter am ziel
kinderspielplatz nachbarschaft chef
vitor reicht ihm das megaphon kein
bedarf ist ja laut genug ist es ernst er
sagt insbesondere die jüngere generation
sei nicht vorbereitet auf
naturkatastrophen tipps vom profi mit
welcher schaufel sich sandsäcke befüllen
lassen und wie eine stabile pappe einem
den helfer erspart und wichtig für die
kommunikation im krisengebiet sandsack
heißt es erst wenn sand drin ist vorher
ein wahnsinnig fit europa ich glaube von
allein wüsste ich nicht wie ich es
anstellen soll
deshalb möchte ich was lernen von herrn
roboter eroberter ist unglaublich
fröhlich fit und mit katastrophen und so
kennt er sich aus
ich finde er ist ein wirklich toller
mensch
japan sei nur zu 30 prozent präpariert
für die vielen drohenden gefahren meinte
potter
viele hätten ja nicht mal eine signal
pfeife er hat einen ganzen karton voll
letzter halt gemeindezentrum es gibt
japanisches curry drinnen kleben die
kinder erobertes lippen weisheiten eines
freiwilligen erstens für deine
gesundheit bist du selbst verantwortlich
zwei nachsichtig mit anderen streng mit
dir selbst und drittens vergiss was du
anderen gutes getan hast behalten lieber
im herzen was andere dir gutes getan
haben
es war ein super tag
vielen dank
[Applaus]
dann hat er auch mal pause und tut was
er sonst nie tut nicht mal im
katastrophengebiet er ist das essen
andere leute bloß niemandem zur last
fallen
aber schluss ist immer noch nicht arbeit
ist nicht gleich beschäftigung sagt
otter und sinnvoll beschäftigen könne
man sich immer doch stets durchkreuzen
groupies seine agenda der preiste
popularität vielleicht könnte ich das
auch in kleinen schritten und wenn alle
mitmachen kann man irgendwann allen
menschen helfen in japan und weltweit
über das essen haben wir uns unterhalten
wer meint man kann nur mit reis mit
eingelegter pflaume überleben was für
ein interessanter mensch plastik in der
nahrungskette die heimsuchung im fisch
verliebten japan
ich mache das nicht für andere
irgendwann trifft es mich auch selbst
und um mich zu schützen schütze ich die
tiere des meeres kaum da und der umwelt
ritter ist auch hier umzingelt von
verehrerinnen kein problem sagt otter
ich bin berühmt dafür frauen zu umarmen
sagen sie doch nicht so etwas
unanständiges hdo obama als arm aber
glücklich
airport tokio narita besuch aus okinawa
ein freitag die freunde lernen fleißig
nur yutaka nicht der macht ja schulfrei
in tokio machen die aktionen mit anderen
darauf freue ich mich total physisch und
psychisch stark bleiben das erklärt ihm
heute im video kampfsportler micro es
akut früher auch mal schulschwänzer und
heute wie yutaka internet-star und
lebensberater und wir kommen dann auch
noch vor
das ist ja
die ich über jetzt jeden tag und beim
nächsten treffen zeige ich ihnen dann
eine trennung erfolge auch wenn man
seine freiheit auslebt ist es mit
verantwortung verbunden wird es
vielleicht manchmal schwer haben aber
auch dann soll er sich treu bleiben und
nicht von seinem weg abweichen
nach treffen mit einem buchverleger am
abend check in im tokyo full house
zwecks horizont erweiterung das full
house ist eine große wohngemeinschaft
familie koyama hebel so japans
einstudierten alltag aus das gefällt
yutaka doch der hausherr man ihn auch
zur mäßigung
yutaka soll nicht glauben dass seine
denkweise alles ist er muss auch den
standpunkt der anderen tolerieren die
traditionell leben normal zur schule
gehen und spaß dabei haben
das full house lebt gemeinschaft
außerhalb der familie in japan sonst maß
aller dinge
hier hilft man sich gegenseitig leute
mit unterschiedlichen wertvorstellungen
ich wollte dass yutaka eine solche
umgebung und die menschen darin selbst
trost das leben ist ein abenteuer und
der eintopf fertig yutaka filmt große
bühne schön euch hier kennen zu lernen
ich dachte ihr paare wohnen nicht mit
anderen zusammen aber so ist es echt
spitze geht niemals aus
in tokio ist was los kamera läuft wir
sind an der uni sagt jutta kehr und hier
kommt mein kumpel
ich bin schon los geht's
wer in die schule möchte bitte gutacker
geht eben gleich zu uni aber auch nur
zum tag der offenen tür der renommierten
universität
alles so schön bunt hier der fakultäten
stellen sich vor
alles dreht sich alles bewegt sich
hauptsache kein frontalunterricht yutaka
im bildungsbetrieb kaum zu glauben doch
sichtlich inspiriert
irgendwo zwischen chemischen formeln und
robotik hier ist es anders als in der
grundschule
da hört man immer nur nach dies macht
das aber hier kann man das lernen was
man möchte
das ist super sid nach spaß aus was
möchtest du einmal studieren
ich weiß nicht
müssen die jungs auch noch nicht sie
werden noch früh genug erleben dass es
vielen japanischen unternehmen nicht
darauf ankommt was jemand studiert hat
sondern nur dass sich ins firmen korsett
zu zwängen zählt dann oft mehr als gute
idee viel talent und phantasie geht so
verloren und deshalb ist flucht in
scheinwelten so beliebt in japan
vielmehr noch unter erwachsenen soll es
unter kindern
yutaka an schon in der schule dass was
nicht stimmt mit dem system
doch sein leben lang gegen den strom
schwimmen allein gegen das kollektiv
toll du bist das schwärmen diese
studenten spricht sich rum wer in japan
aus der reihe tanzt aber nur rebell
reicht auch nicht
schule ist ja nicht nur zum lernen da
sondern auch um soziale kompetenz zu
erwerben durch austausch mit
gleichaltrigen die stunde der
akademischen wahrheit sie naht
damit muss er sich beschäftigen wenn er
an die uni will vielleicht sogar an die
beste hier dann reicht es wohl nicht
wenn er nur das macht was er will was
mit robotern wird cool sagte yutaka und
wenn das nicht klappt wird er bestimmt
entertainer
da macht ihm sowieso keiner was vor
west japan berühmt für seine flotte
handtücher dachziegel und für seine dogs
stunde null für yukiko tomita tag eins
auf der schiene china wirft gefühlslage
ganz schön nervös von der firmen wohnung
bis zum tor zwei minuten
verwaltungsleiter mori ist ein großer
fortuna er weiß gute mitarbeiter gibt es
nur in gesunden körper auch tomita
erreicht betriebstemperatur dann
einführung in die firmenphilosophie
jeder mitarbeiter sollte glücklich sein
so wohl nur so habe die firma erfolg
ganz ehrlich es ist das erste mal dass
wir für den beruf eines schiffbau
ingenieurs wien frau tomita ausüben wird
eine frau eingestellt haben weniger geld
aber aufstiegschancen
gestaltungsspielraum statt bürokratie
arbeiten in einem modernen unternehmen
deshalb ist o meter hier und sie kann
auch noch was lernen
bislang hatte ich mit schiffen zu tun
die im rohbau waren oder fast fertig
hier bekomme ich alles mit auch die
herstellung und verarbeitung der
stahlplatten für spezial fragte
chemietanker autofähren na wer kommt
denn da der werksdirektor ein tomita fan
ich hoffe sie gewöhnt sich schnell ein
in diesem männerhaushalt und dann wäre
es schön sie würde eine führungsposition
anstreben um unser unternehmen
voranzubringen so schluss mittagspause
eine kostprobe der männergesellschaft
gibt es in der werkskantine tomita
taucht ein in ein meer aus kernen
es duftet nach nudelsuppe und riecht
nach maloche
[Musik]
das essen ist etwas würziger als in
tokio die arbeiter schwitzen viel
so brauchen das aber man trifft hier
viele leute ich hab mich schon ein
bisschen unterhalten
das freut mich sehr
dauerlauf durch großraumbüro das
strategische herzstück der werft ihr
neuer arbeitsplatz die software kennt
sie dienstpläne produktionspläne bekommt
sie in den griff vorstellung in der
verwaltung auch in uniformen die damen
aber näher am japanischen standard wir
müssen ja nicht an die fertigung worte
photometer schon das ist bestimmt
anstrengend ich wünsche ihr viel erfolg
mit frauen am arbeitsplatz ist die
stimmung fröhlicher sie sind wie blumen
japans arbeitswelt ist männlich bei der
gleichstellung liegt das land global
weit hinten automieter will das ändern
am richtigen fleck ich hab das meer vor
der tür und berge gibt es auch und in
der umgebung kann man mandarinen
pflücken und zitronen
dafür brauche ich nicht viel geld das
ist ein ganz anderer luxus salz in tokio
mal was neues
das kann man wohl sagen
quito meter in berlin das eis ist
gebrochen
[Musik]